lorsque vous conduisez une voiture
s'appliquer le code de la route et
femmes enceintes leurs passagers c'est
la vie encore le poids d'une voiture
c'est pourquoi dans le droit des femmes
je les trucs qui est l impression de ne
pas pouvoir faire juste parce que tu
aimes pas en l'avortement libre et quand
on est blessé
mais non
vous c'est quoi ce délire tu chic
expériences sexuelles ou tamouls j'en
sais rien menu des blocs tu vas pas
retourner dans l'air est là bas mais
c'est trop pour ma mère je n'ai jamais
fait ça avec personne alors j'y vais je
peux pas faire autrement mais on s'est
connu un groupe de femmes un groupe de
poterie pour femmes mais tu fais de
choses sur toi est très doué en plus
avait toute une série de très jolis
petits base est ce que tu te rends
compte que ta mère s imagine que tu va
épouser antoine qu'elle va devenir grand
mère si tu veux juste qu'on est ensemble
tu vas pas lui mentir tous terry qu'est
ce que tu cherches que je te sert
d'alibi je vais partir marcher
ce qui est sûr pour quitter l'émission
quand je veux clichy coup
des films dont ceux qui seraient
d'accord avec ça